mcs non ci stiamo non lo vedo del futuro
che io voglio io sono un futuro grande
sogno un futuro top con una persona top
come una famiglia top come la mia sono
arrivato a pensare che a vent'anni forse
dovrà avere quella leggerezza in più nel
vivere le cose forse sono io il pollo
che non vuole stare con la polla la pole
e lei io sto con lei il piacere di stare
con lei perché la amo
non per altri motivi che col resto bene
basta no comment ha definito il nostro
rapporto moloto non mi pare gravi che su
tutti i giorni andare a fare bungee
jumping parla male di medici fatti
nostri augurate neanche conosci sei
cattivo se ad oggi posso dirti che
ragionerò solo con la testa e non con il
cuore perché fino ad ora ha sempre usato
al cuore e nicola il risultato di questo
io incoerente io immatura mi hai proprio
perche io che sono l'uomo posso anche
vari cretino perché c'era nella natura
mia però essa deve stare zitta avuta e
non dare confidenza agli altri questo è
quello che penso che non è sicuramente
la piccoli nato cresciuto io mi
aspettavo che dopo tre giorni mi
chiamassero perché sarah voleva
confronto è invece balla fuma beve una
cosa veramente indecente ma deluso
fedeli io sono messo l'anima questo
ragazzo credete questi cinque anni sono
stati vent'anni devi capire io parto
sempre rispetto cioè io pensavo
veramente devana vaniglia con lui capito
chiamami matta lo so però io l'ho
accettato per la lenticchia che ha detto
che ho fatto passa tre giorni di inferno
venite potevo di quello che vedevo senza
manco aprirlo lei che parla i docenti
canali che parlavano di me che spa
lanzago vega polare e anche perché do
stipendi ma ogni volta che pure qualcosa
batte cassa quindi come ci chiedono la
palla mentre d'altro come po dà fastidio
perché me la sua scelta così è a monte
quando andammo a balla gli dico senti
fame a morte c a ballabio la perché mi
vergogno
sono amareggiata figli credimi è
completamente partito si è completamente
scortato di avere una fidanzata
dall'altra parte ma qui stiamo sbarbo
lando filippo io ho 32 anni non voglio
fare la fidanzatina vita a lui lo sa lei
gli devo navigli lucciconi agli occhi è
quello che faccio che lei lo coccolata
viziata comprato borse chanel viaggi
veduto quanto me rode er culo supererà
[Musica]